doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz
[Musik]
fliegen
leicht wie ein vogel
[Musik]
ein kindheitstraum
ikarus kam der sonne zu nahe und stürzte
in den tod
die sehnsucht jedoch bleibt um spielbar
[Musik]
und wie gehabt das fliegen
die flugroute dass das nicht gut steht
der luft
[Musik]
wir sehen dass sich alle bürger bis am
puls gefühlt da ist einmal der fels der
hof und das ich finde bewegung also dass
durch die ganzheitliche trotzdem hoch
browser also ich wirklich was los und da
hat jetzt prof
[Musik]
die felsigen flanken der churfirsten
thronen hoch über dem walensee ein
ideales gelände für wings sprenger
michael schwieriges ziel ist der sputnik
ein beliebter und anspruchsvoller exit
er hat hingegen 50 mal gesprungen
im absprung ich habe mich am anfang die
erst 34 sekunden bis das liegt also
wissen sich mit luft gefüllt hat dies
mit hoher geschwindigkeit hat habe ich
alles vom absprung aber so wie schön
dass man ab springt sie vom absprung
nicht wir kriegen möglichst weit weg vom
felsen und ihnen gut die positionierung
weil man sich irgendwie es falsch ist
oder einfach schon george war wirklich
hart am limit früh greifen
darum versuche ich kann
[Musik]
hier hat afrika
tatsächlich lauterbrunnen gilt weltweit
als das mekka die vielen bergbahnen
bringen die piloten bequem zu den
zahlreichen exits
zudem gibt es kaum ein land in dem die
gesetzgebung punktespringen derart
liberal ist wie in der schweiz
deshalb zählt das lauterbrunnental
jährlich über 20.000 mails sprünge von
sportlern aus der ganzen welt
[Musik]
rok
lissabon
gott
bonn
[Musik]
olcay sahan
ja und das ist dort mit der bruno 1000er
so negativ krise im umkreis wird so
helfen wir der matten einer der stars
wie die vita wer hier
da wird eigentlich praktisch unverändert
und ausnahmeregelungen so cool ich habe
auch hier auf dem auto kamen am beten
sie im base jumper 300g zünden die
erlegen im ruf die straße spezi
umstritten aber wenn man mal so einfach
potsdam zusammen weiß ob sie was das
leben von stan bringt das trinkwasser
bringt was für totale bringt es ist
einfach versuchen ist ihnen zu richten
region und braucht auch mehr oder
weniger jährigen auf eine art und durch
das ist sagen hier zu ihrem belegt war
man muss ihnen sprach von easy capture
pro moto okimo mittleren bis auf der
ganze welt in hannover läuft schon die
mengen es ist ein scherz zu kriegen im x
form hat muss schon das plötzliche an
der hütte bauen wenn man als aktueller
werden als talkshow einfach ein wenig
sehen wie wir mit damit umgehen
der kollege am vormittag deutlich
komplexer sein kollege war mit musik
sprung am vormittag auch die ich einmal
damit auch wer das ist nicht
ungefährlich scheren darf
das ist heute sportart dass zwischen den
herpes wo geht ja dass er gehen doch gar
nicht passieren sagt schon der beste
beste sich um ein abkommen dass ich
einfach so riesig war sie sich verhalten
wenn der motor fällt wenn halb verrückt
oder tafel über grimsel hin und her
werkstatt der quali aber dem begegnet
sieg war eigentlich nochmal sich das ist
einfach so und sport event darf sich das
bisschen hart aber ich bin nun schon zu
einem boot holen und das ist das prinzip
aber das ist die alaba und damit der
staat und damit und was ist eigentlich
das höchste der gefühle
probier das neue jugendhaus nicht längst
nicht alle basejumper die sich in diesem
absprung buch eingetragen haben sind
noch am leben
michael schwere hatte an diesem exit
garbo verloren seinen mexikanischen
freund der heimischen mexiko gebaut und
springen keine kleinen mexiko geschafft
und mit einem wochenend wilco
fallschirmspringen und erika dixie und
dann irgendwie erfahren dass air base
bringt und bei 98 fragt doch nur das
magazin kabul plante bei einem besuch in
der schweiz mit schwerem sputnik zu
springen
doch genau an diesem tag wollte schwere
mit der familie seinen geburtstag feiern
christian haller ist fahrer jeden herbst
hätte auf der alb zingler den
traditionellen berggottesdienst ein paar
hundert meter unterhalb des sputnik exit
während parallel seine predigt hält
ahnte nicht dass sich hoch über ihm
garbo zum sprung bereit macht sich heine
von der erste schöne zum dixi robert
überhaupt die mühe und zeit einige wagen
gestartet sind sind immer wieder
aufregend wie die leute drauf mit den
schweren und mehr von mir drinnen wäre
dem gottesdienst sind einige wieder
gestartet und erst einmal das lead-in
wieder darauf trainiert aber man das
fasziniert sich faszinierend sollte den
slogan oder mit dem neuen auto tödlich
verunglückt ist das ordentlich gestartet
so tönt wie normal
ich bin aufgeschreckt wurden wundert
lucio und kaká hat weil das gibt ein
knallen oder in der schule gehabt und
den absturz bezirks sind denn da das
steile gras abrollt oder denkt ihr
inzwischen eingegangen
das ist eigentlich und ein kreis eine
entweder steigen
das hat man liebe schlager oder
irgendwas und dann hat das habe ich in
diez lang warten
in kraft der region zu machen striptease
ins den verletzten zu hilfe eilt und ihr
größtes tragen wir den islam mit dem
entschiedenen gottesdienst wittert
führen
ja noch eine fürbitte hat formuliert für
abgestürzte bezirks ist vor allem für
sich angehörige und weil die welt sich
in folge gebe zu den zwergen fast 430
richtig wenn mal wieder machen
der prestige halten
wow
basejumping ab jetzt führt nur noch ein
ausgesetzter alpinfahrer zur
absprungstelle auf den 2400 meter hohen
gipfel im kanton uri
[Musik]
wingsuit ist eine männerdomäne umso mehr
sticht géraldine fasnacht heraus sie ist
eine der wenigen profis in szene
vorderhand verdeckten jedoch lästige
wollten die notwendige sicht nicht gut
ich jetzt mit der situation jetzt
nachgerade flüge und dann als 20 jährige
gehörte géraldine fasnacht zu den besten
extrem snowboarderinnen der welt
[Musik]
celal dienst erster ehemann ein walliser
bergführer starb am gleitschirm
skifahren vor ihren augen
[Musik]
für marie der ewig manchmal fliegen
traum und vergesse den schirm zu öffnen
das ist wirklich stressig
[Musik]
schon von klein an weisen einen traum zu
fliegen und jetzt kann ich es machen das
ist magisch für mich du hast ja gar
keine federn hat man mir immer wieder
gesagt hör auf zu träumen
du bist ein kleines mädchen und kein
vogel das ist doch unglaublich wie ein
vogel mit den flügeln manövrieren zu
können
für diesen sport muss man sich selber
sehr genau einschätzen und die regeln
befolgen
es gibt keine routine und es ist nie
leicht
als wäre es das erste mal muss man wie
ein flugzeug pilot alles genau befolgen
man muss ihn lieben seine träume
realisieren denn das leben ist kurz
dabei aber keine unnötigen risiken
eingehen
sie markiert
[Musik]
hass auf den stein auf
ok
singen
[Musik]
und wenn nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der traum vom fliegen frei wie ein vogel
aber das todesrisiko fliegt aus dem
friedlichen lauterbrunnen gehen wir mit
gebremst gestartet
aufgeschoben und ich bin christ water
der nabu gestanden und das ist schon als
pc aber da ich natürlich mehr dort werde
sofort begonnen
der verlust des lebens die dunkle seite
des wintersports
hinter jedem namen verbirgt sich ein
schicksal
seit 1981 verzeichnet die fatalities ist
weltweit sämtliche wingsuit todesopfer
der aktuelle stand liegt bei über 270
verstorbenen
u
der gleitschirm arbeiten der versorger
machen für atlanta fliegen und mit der
thermik herstellern und so weiter dass
das fasziniert sich das begriffen und
das die jungs so macht daniel wolf
verständnis in garantie basecamp
insofern wichtig da nicht einverstanden
ist sagen ja dass nico das zwar nicht
oder so dann ist für die tiere brandort
nicht ganz worden
[Musik]
michael schwedisch bringt selten in
lauterbrunn als chef von 35 mitarbeitern
im bereich gebäudetechnik ist die
typische t shirt springer szene eher
fremd
wingsuit ist und bleibt ein risikosport
schwerer hat als familienvater eine
verantwortung gegenüber seiner frau und
seiner kleinen tochter
[Musik]
diskussionspunkt sie mal pause macht
er habe zu wenig vorsichtiger aber
verbietet und erwachsen und weiß was er
macht und jetzt kein garantieversprechen
völlig versperrt
also ich bin ich okay wenn der traum vom
flüge ich eine schöne traum
[Musik]
man was machen woher kommt die sehnsucht
des menschen nach dem freien fliegen
denn darin hat die kleine emilia recht
der mensch ist kein vogel ikarus kam in
seiner flug begeisterung der sonne zu
nahe und stürzte in den tod
fliegen das taten die hexen das gehört
zur abgründigen seite der menschlichen
existenz stets drohte der sündhafte
sturz in luzifer ische tiefen homo
volans der fliegende mensch ein unding
[Musik]
in der tat gingen die allermeisten
flugversuche unglücklich aus wie bei
einem schneider aus der 1811 vor den
augen der ganzen stadt im fluss landete
und entsprechend verspottet wurde
der schneider von ulm hat flieger
probiert nur hatten der reifen und donau
wird
der menschlichen erfinder kraft scheinen
bei den flug konstruktionen keine
grenzen gesetzt zu sein
[Musik]
auch das militär interessierte sich für
neuartige einsetzbare flug soldaten
der österreichische schneidermeister
franz reichel tanna bot sich von einer
57 meter hohen plattform des eiffelturms
seine flug vorrichtung zu demonstrieren
zum amüsement der pariser bourgeoisie
es war der vierte februar 1912 der boden
steinhart gefroren reichel zögert und
merklich auf dem wackeligen stuhl eine
vorahnung seines nahen todes
[Musik]
akribisch wird das ein schlagloch des
opfers ausgemessen
es ist 14 zentimeter tief
[Musik]
im christentum symbolisiert der
menschliche flug dass sich empor heben
zu gott
zentral für die erlangung des heils
[Musik]
verbindet mit dem mit dem übersinnlichen
mit dem überirdischen mit dem mit dem
was ich selber überstieg ich das nicht
für master computing wo jesus
hauptbahnhof der berg für tennis oder
bezirks ist vom tempel und exakte haben
oder und wenn das macht schon sinn und
einzelne nicht macht er hält sich mit
für versuche wichtig dass hier in lotte
ich mag es ist matthäus 446 wenn du
person bis zu wirklich hin ab denn es
ist geschrieben dass er seinen engeln
gebieten wie gehabt und sie sollen die
ich habe deinen händen tragen auch dass
er seinen fuß nicht an einen stein stoss
ist sprach jesus zu ihm wiederum ist
geschrieben du sollst den herrn deinen
gott nicht versuchen
ich denke dass es ein großes risiko die
projektgesellschaften mehr sind das
immer so aber stücke wie verrückte
sachen ausprobieren
der krieg
ein produkt ist angelique kerber kennt
sich als ehemalige flight attendant mit
dem fliegen aus heute arbeitet sie als
luftfahrtmanager in ihr vater und bruder
sind beide piloten ihr ehemann patrick
hat einige der anspruchsvollsten bin
super sprünge in den schweizer alpen
realisiert sie solche zwölf jahre her
sieht nach vorne haben und kaum groß -
2000 springt wort und ich habe mich von
meinen erfahrungen sammeln wo mir
natürlich habe erlaubt situationen gut
in schätze und das mögliche so als mini
lebensversicherung dass es einfach darum
gott dir punkte beachten
man kann also die erika uhr schließen
kann und das bin ich meiner frau
schuldig dass ich alles dafür tun dass
sich machen könnte auf der straße
überfahren werden
oder ich an krebs sterben deshalb darf
ich ihm niemals seinen traum vom fliegen
wegnehmen
viele leute denken winslet hat etwas mit
adrenalin kick zu tun
aber patrick fliegt wie ein blut er hat
seinen flugplan
er schaut auf das wetter all das hat
nichts mit todessehnsucht oder
männlichkeits gebaren zu tun
für ihn ist es eine wissenschaft
die frage michael hüther das atelier du
machst es doch viel draußen und
untersuchen was sagt ihr zu dass sie
gedopt und ich empfinde ich mitwirke
kategorien dass die die zieht es im film
sondern für mich sehr technisch ich
brachte essig flüge dann genau die route
und ich plane das land das schon vor mir
weil ich genau die route und ich brauche
kann ich gar nicht genau nach plan vor
ich springe dann ich lande und es ist
das gefühl vor erfüllung altstadt von
tallinn also spielen ist irgendwie das
gefühl ich muss unterschreiben und was
ich jetzt hat überlebt sondern für mich
ist in einer so realisation ich frage
dann gerne nochmal ufer und jetzt
einfach locker bin und landet dann
nochmals revue passieren und bin
wirklich sehr zufrieden mit dem was
jetzt passiert ist
[Musik]
an einem solchen krachts tag treten sich
am jungfrau gipfel die bergsteiger
gegenseitig auf die füße für sie alle
erfüllt sich an diesem tag ein lang
gehegter traum
auch patrick aber ist zusammen mit
seinem freund franz toni am aufstieg
[Musik]
aber auf ihrer route sind sie allein
denn ihr ziel ist die benachbarte wengen
jungfrau 4100 meter hoch von diesem exit
will kerber seinem weltrekord sprung aus
dem jahre 2013 übertrumpfen
dieses mal will er mit einer neuen noch
anspruchsvolleren fluglinie über das
spektakuläre silber und fliegen über
sechs jahre hinweg hat er dieses projekt
minutiös geplant
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was ist der größte unterschied ist das
merke ich immer wieder wenn ich mit
meinem vater unterwegs bin werkstücke
mit kollegen von mir gibt ist ein
prinzips ziel und dass wir das
zurückbekommen hat wie zum beispiel der
eigen und nicht interessiert nur
bocksprung stellen also ich muss doch da
geht verloren das ziel erreicht ist so
ein mist ziel ist immer auch strom und
banken und das ist sicher ein großer
unterschied zu den organismus
als erstes bereitet franz die
absicherung vor damit der patrick in die
senkrechte nordflanke ablassen kann
es ist soweit
patrick ifd sich über den schnee kramm
um zuerst einmal den aktuellen zustand
des sexy zu prüfen war nachhaltig vom
gipfel verlegung versprechen so bewusst
wie schwierig das ganze könnte werde
wir sind dann aber schon mal jungfrau
chance besteht bekommt sind bis auf den
gipfeln und hans klein schmal angelegt
und damals sind sogar nicht aus dass sie
und dann doch all die jahre
fotos mal richtig studiert dann immer
den superstar immer dafür verbürgt und
dann womöglich anfang habe ich mich
nicht mit james ich mir dann irgendwann
wollte den humor der eine jungfrau ist
das schön auszeichnen und ich bin dann
relativ rasch tun sie das mit einer art
zum glück nur kurz flüge wird das aber
habe ich dann mit den mitteln kollegen
dran habe ich geschaut dass wir morgen
auf der kippe steht wohnt muss massa mit
dem angeklagten gehabt genug hört man
von potenziellen absprung
[Musik]
stephan sigrist ist profi rabin ist
schon früh hat ihn das springen von
geeigneten felsen fasziniert und mehr
service ist häufig das ist standard base
cap mir verschiedenen disziplinen an den
alu oder begibt des hauptsitzes von
avantis tracy und die verschiedene spiel
folgen inzwischen so komplex wie zum
beispiel aber stieg auf einer bank und
springen mit links zu da ist immer noch
nass sondern sie beschneiden sprung der
geistigen ist ja schon da war eigentlich
der abstieg sicher und konzentriert
weiter und hat das klare energie hätte
nicht geheim dass man versucht solide
untersuchten autos
der paria alpinismus bringt einen
neuartigen umgang mit dem berg magic
mushroom so heißt eine der schwierigsten
kletterrouten in der eigernordwand sie
christ gelingt 2009 erstmals die
durchsteigung die route ist
anspruchsvoll und 27 sei lang lang die
nacht verbringt er mit seiner partner in
der wand doch damit nicht genug
diese alpine parforce leistung für ein
sí christ mit einem zusätzlichen
höhepunkt ich bestimmt dass man die
konzentration aufrecht erhalten
das war aber nach zwei anspruchsvoller
lange schlafen natürlich tempi wacker
chemie 100 prozentig konzentriert ist
und nichts anderes fritz rabatz machen
will
gute frisur oder muss setzte
[Musik]
da muss ich schon mal nachts spezielles
sieht dass man etc möglich war ein
zweiter versuch möglichst nicht stürzen
sich möglichst teure wand rechts habe
und wirtschaftsreferenten minute muss
man ein hopp und stürzt sich genau die
zutat eigentlich versucht aber jetzt nur
noch endspiele
die stanz machen aus einem unbedachten
fehler
das fing an als nachfolger gefunden
wer springt nimmt freiwillig ein risiko
auf sich
[Musik]
nein berührungsängste hat bauer art von
einem keine wieso nicht einmal selber
ausprobieren wie sich das da oben in der
luft anfühlt
und 2
[Musik]
das ist wunderbar aber sich dann doch
heldmann staub und im st
[Musik]
aber wie ergeht es freunden und
verwandten die bsg am boden um ihre
liebsten bangen das warten ist am
schwierigsten
wenn die gedanken kreisen und die ängste
galoppieren endlich sein erlösende anruf
kommt das wäre einfacher für mich wenn
diese angst nicht da wäre
gott sei dank ist er immer früh
unterwegs und ich versuche so lange wie
möglich zu schlafen ist er sich meldet
wenn ich patrick das fliegen verbieten
würde wäre er nicht mehr die person die
er jetzt ist
und das darf man niemandem antun
wingsuit ist seine leidenschaft das ist
für ihn eine art meditation
er übt das fliegen als eine kunstform
aus und genau deshalb habe ich mein herz
an den verwirrung
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die entscheidende phase
patrick seil zum exit ab
das ist hochalpin brand der
gletschermann zum absprung abseilen
man muss er vor gericht machen immer
starten den oberlauf den grad des
angeblich starken schöne der sonne
das ist eine große sache friedlich und
für mich ist das gefühl der krieg auch
dem anspruch auf den job sein
die nordwand richtigen oder falschen job
das ist alles dunkel der fans wird böse
das hat die branche sein und dann merkt
man schnell dass man anderweitig und
dann müsste ja der flüge zum rad machen
sich bewusst sie das wirklich einen sehr
anspruchsvollen abstimmung ist als der
flughafen auf einheimische kräfte
ziemlich kurz mit 107 40 drop teilen und
ein stuhl fax positiv das heißt egal in
welcher stadt
[Musik]
ich glaube ist mit seinen gedanken bei
mir eher fokussiert seinen flug die
risiken aber er ist zuversichtlich sonst
würde er den sprung machen
deshalb habe ich vertrauen in ihn
was ganz speziellen ist auch richtig
dass man eigentlich im hochalpinen
gelände springt wirklich schnell und
flüssig und kommt dann langsam gefällt
sich geschichten und dann auf einmal
konstruieren dazu von der bau im
fotofinish vor der von der gras und dann
fliegt man diese produkte wohnen aber er
kriegt die grüne weide sind mit aber die
touristen wo man auch dass das ganze ein
spezielles spiel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber wenn einmal kinder da sind stellt
sich die frage ob das fliegen ein
solches risiko wird ist aber das muss
jeder selber für sich beantworten
[Gelächter]
der traum vom fliegen
[Musik]
er birgt große risiken
über 2.000 springer hat patrick kramer
durchgeführt
doch einige monate nach seinem
erfolgreichen jungfernflug verunglückte
er tödlich
er geriet unversehens in eine nebelbank
und verlor die orientierung
patrick bezahlte seine leidenschaft mit
dem leben
die faszination des ikarus im freien
flug
sie bleibt bestehen
[Musik]
doch mit dem neuen toyota rav 4 4 x 4
und hybrid die ideale kombination für
die schweiz